[Music]
hello and welcome to another wolfram
tech talk i am arvin khalsichi still and
today i'm here with alan joyce who works
on socioeconomic data in wolframalpha
and today he'll be telling us a little
bit about an exciting new partnership we
have with microsoft where a lot of this
data that's in wolframalpha is getting
integrated into excel so you can access
it straight from excel alan
yeah well hey that's about the whole
story that was great okay thanks great
thank you thank you well we've we've
been um we've been
in this partnership with microsoft for
over a year now um
we've um
what we've been working on is as you
said a way for people to get direct
access to
a lot of the content that we have in the
wolf knowledge base all of the
most of the entities and properties that
are accessible through wolfram alpha but
also accessible directly through the
wolfram language through entity value
and other other functions
but making that just directly available
in excel so you can
type or copy lists of entity names of
more than 100 different types of things
into excel
click a button
essentially that's going through the
wool from alpha parser trying to
understand what types of things those
are resolve those two specific entities
and then you can do some really cool
stuff with that directly in excel you
know those those things then in excel
aren't just
um strings in a in a cell in a
spreadsheet they're sort of more dynamic
entities that have all sorts of other
data associated with them
so you can you can pull up a card and
look at all the properties that are
exposed in excel
you can click on properties and pull
them out into the spreadsheet and then
you can compute with those if they're
quantitative values you can just write
formulas in excel and you can do all the
kinds of things you would normally do in
excel sheet right so instead of having
just like a string that says you know
the uk or something like that right and
access
well i guess specific uh to what you're
working on socioeconomic data so you get
population statistics income statistics
you know you could get whether you get
any of this stuff just kind of
accessible right in excel
right and and some of those things are
uh more static values you know things
like population that might get updated
every year so but in some domains things
like some of the astronomical domains um
where some of the properties of a planet
or a star or something are very time and
location dependent um then that's the
other cool thing you know you click on
something like you know what's the next
rise time for mars and it's going to
actually go back to the wolf mouth
server and figure out okay well you're
here and this is this date and here's
the actual value for today and then in
excel you can
refresh a spreadsheet you can get more
you know refresh all the values that can
be time and and place dependent and get
more updated values when you need them
share those note those uh spread i
always want to call everything notebooks
but share those spreadsheets with other
people uh and and they can access that
data um so it's really cool and you know
it's it's been a big effort for a lot of
people
uh on the world from alpha side uh
people working on wolfram language
people in wolfram solutions a big
partnership with people across the
country the company and with people in
microsoft um who have been just great
partners on working with this and trying
to expose more of this content and
functionality to people
um i mean i can i can show some examples
of you know what we've what we've kind
of worked on and what's available to
people
let me just
start here
i think probably first thing
you know there's there's some some good
resources online that give you a better
overview of what the partnership is
about and kind of how things look in
different domains
um you know this is just sort of the
general overview of of what we have
available
some highlighting some specific examples
you know there's food data that's
accessible through excel so people can
do
meal trackers nutrition planners all
kinds of data that you can pull out
space and astronomy there are a lot of
good uses
for a lot of domains here that we think
in education you know i lots of people
have access to wolfram language in in
schools and universities
but you know obviously excel is another
thing that some some teachers some
classrooms are more familiar with they
have some resources they're also using
so this is just a great way to get more
wolfram content in front of people in a
really easy to use kind of dynamic way
you know like you mentioned cities being
able to pull out a lot of demographic
socio-economic data you know again kind
of in an educational context but also
you know for people who are you know
business owners people doing marketing
people who want to have
uh some more you know up-to-date data on
different aspects of
cities counties states zip codes all
that kind of stuff is also accessible
directly through excel now
thanks to the wolfram integration
um
like i said there's there's a lot that's
exposed
not everything that's accessible through
wolfram alpha and the wolfram language
but
more than 100 different entity types you
know you can see spanning a lot of
different domains so uh you know space
and astronomy a lot of
physical geography points of interest
structures animals biology earth science
uh different types of exercises there
yeah exactly uh and that they mean that
in addition
along with food
i think is one of the domains that we
and microsoft have been particularly
excited about because they seem like
more natural ways for sort of general
users of excel to get into this you know
something like tracking your meals
tracking your activity these are things
that a lot of people commonly do in
excel
and with the the data and the
computation that we make available here
it just opens up a lot of other things
you know it it lets people just type in
an activity you know i went running for
an hour you know six miles at this pace
and we can compute you know calories
burned and all sorts of other things for
that so it's a cool thing to enable just
some some very everyday kind of uses and
also more
uh you know technical educational
scientific uses in excel all right so
that's a really good way for people who
are maybe a little bit less familiar
with maybe they're not
scientists or maybe they're not working
on economics or something they're not
maybe used to working with numerix this
is a great way for them to kind of
access all this computational knowledge
and computational ability without having
to sit there and learn you know
about how to access all this stuff in a
programmatic way necessarily right uh
we've all you know we've also created
for each of the entity types exposed in
excel we've created
um you know type specific pages so
people can go to these
you know again
linking back
from that previous page
you know be able to go through and take
a look at
uh you know what are some of the kinds
of entities that are accessible in this
domain what are properties you can
access
you know lots of kind of interesting
things there
yeah i can i can show a little bit more
about how exactly this works i'm not
sure if
it might be helpful if i
zoomed in here a little bit more um
but
okay
you know just
very basically you know the the
fundamental way that people interact
with things here in excel is
you've got a list of some kind of entity
uh and those again could be planets they
could be foods they could be exercises
they could be cities um you
type or copy paste however you've
imported them into an excel sheet
you select those cells and then you go
to the data tab up here
and
you can see if you pull this down there
there's a small number of of
what microsoft refers to as data types
you know for us these are sort of like
collections of wolfram language entity
types um
there's a small number that are sort of
uh
microsoft created their built-in things
stocks currencies some geographic
features
the rest of this stuff down here is all
wolfram content
and so these are these are not
individual entity types in some cases
like movies
it's really just movie entities but in
with things like
chemistry this could be
elements chemicals um you know other
kinds of things
for
structures you know that spans
ridges buildings canals dams all these
kinds of things so there's a meta entity
right
yeah exactly
um
and if you don't really know what you're
looking for you can also just click
automatic and that's going to try to get
all the possible things that that a
given a
set of strings might correspond to
so kind of also giving you a sense a
little bit more about some of the things
that that happen behind the scenes and
what we're trying to do here um so we'll
say mercury jupiter and mars
i'm going to click automatic
just for whatever reason maybe i don't
know what i want to resolve that to
and what's going to pop up here is
a disambiguation pane you know kind of
like you get in wolfram alpha or you're
getting the wolfram language where
if there's any ambiguity about what a
specific input
should be interpreted as you're going to
make some choices and so in this case
you know we've got mercury jupiter and
mars and because there are
a number of different possible
interpretations of each of those
we're going to make you try to choose
which thing you might mean and so you
can go over here and say yeah i
definitely want planets i can click
through here and say yeah turn those all
into planets
um if you have a little bit better sense
of the general domain you're looking for
you could also go in here and say
you know what i i want space i don't
want given names i don't want fictional
characters and so that will also help to
limit and you know here we go straight
to the planets
the other thing that we're doing is also
taking into account um context in the
spreadsheet and so you know it could be
something as simple as you've put a
heading on a column
and when you select a a span of cells
we're going to look and see you know is
there column headers there's something
there that that kind of matches one of
the domains that we cover and so even in
this case then if i say automatic we're
going to look up there and we're gonna
say uh okay planets yeah we think those
are the planets and results of that
um you know once you've resolved uh a
string and turn it into an entity then
you can go in and you know every entity
is gonna have one of these little icons
to indicate that it's it's an entity
it's not just a string in that cell and
you can click on that icon and that's
going to pop up
one of these cards that's going to have
available
all of the properties that we've made
accessible through excel and so you can
scroll down here you know these are kind
of like wool from alphapods these are
collected into
uh you know pods in a card here so
you've got orbital properties you've got
uh there's a lot of things for astro
domains physical properties atmosphere
some of these are even pulling in
images that we're generating on our side
so something like a sky map
you pull that up and this is actually
going and like we do in wolfram alpha or
in the wolfram language this is going to
generate
a sky map for right now for wherever
your user location is and then you could
pull that out into the spreadsheet
but kind of going through this you know
you've got a you got a property that you
want to pull out um i don't know largest
distance from the sun
you could click on that
and that will just drop that property
value into the spreadsheet
and the cool thing here is then you know
that that cell is not just uh
a number
this is really a formula in excel and
what it is is
this is you know
e2 whatever the entity is in e2
and then it is this property of that
entity so then i could take this and i
could pull that down
and that's going to copy not the value
but that formula down into those cells
so if you've got a big row of entities
you can just go ahead and do that and
and just populate your whole spreadsheet
with values for a particular property or
range of properties
um
you could also
if you go in you select something like
this you could say
you know i want to turn this into an
actual excel table that's where my data
is
and then
you can just start going from here and
say you know what i want to get
average diameter i want to get
i want to get temperature and it's going
to start pulling those things out and
generating a table for you
so you know very cool and then whatever
you want to do with these things you can
you can do other kinds of computations
you can do other kinds of operations on
the values that you've got out in your
spreadsheet
you know one thing that that is not
supported in excel and i'll just shout
out the things that are very cool about
the wolfram language
there is no sense of an actual unit
system in excel
yeah yeah and so but if you go into the
cards for something what you've got
attached to each of these properties is
what the actual units are for that
property so that that information is
getting passed through it's just that
when you pull out some numeric value
into the spreadsheet right right this
this isn't anything more complex than
just uh
because you'd have to combine you know a
number and a string in there and then
that might mess with the computations
you want to do so right that makes sense
i mean that's that's some something
hopefully on the horizon something we've
talked about a lot and i think it's
obvious to people who've used this but
the value that would be there and you
know comparatively the
if you really need access to that kind
of thing the the power of what you've
got in the wolfram language um
[Music]
yeah but i think there's you know
there's a there's a whole host of things
there are also some
uh
templates that we've worked on that uh
microsoft has done a lot of the design
work here but
there are some very cool templates that
they've set up that are focused on some
specific kind of popular areas
that people use in excel either for
education or other things so we've got
um you know planets i think we've got
another one for
uh
yeah nutrition tracking they've set up
kind of these these nice things so that
to give people a better sense you know
instead of just going to a blank
spreadsheet and start typing things in
here's some nice kind of formatted stuff
that deuce that does some dynamic uh you
know visualizations of things so i can
go in here and say like
two slices of
bacon
and
yeah because this is coming in a cell
that's after a bunch of other foods it's
going to try to just automatically
resolve that
and these cells yeah these cells have
already got some
you know formulas that they're auto
populating so
it's this kind of thing that also you
know excel has a lot of great
functionality for
building templates and doing these kinds
of automated things and so combining
that with
all the just ready-made data that that
we're putting into excel it just opens
up a lot of other cool things that
people can do yeah that's that's pretty
fantastic i didn't even realize when you
first opened this that this was a
spreadsheet i missed the uh the
header labels and the row labels here
so someone who doesn't
as someone who doesn't personally spend
a lot of time working in spreadsheets um
yeah that you know but this this is the
kind of thing that that a lot of people
in a lot of different settings do in
excel and then you can do a lot of
really
powerful flexible dynamic things and so
combining that with
access to just all the hundreds of
different data types and thousands of
properties and data points
you know it's a really neat feature it's
something we're excited to see people
starting to use in excel and and
all the cool stuff people are able to do
yeah and you mentioned briefly
educational purposes i could certainly
see you know an instructor putting
together some sort of template like this
that their students could use to learn
about any of these things you know be it
planets or exercises or nutrition
or you know state capitals or what have
you
chemistry i think there's another
there's another really cool template
that we put together that's you know one
of the sheets in the in the workbook is
the periodic table and so you can click
on that and get you know other kinds of
properties of any of those elements pop
up there are other tabs that let you
sort and play around with different
aspects of of elements it's it's really
cool a really nice way for
students who've got access to this this
functionality to
explore and play around with things a
little more dynamically and and also get
people exposed to you know some of what
wolfram is about in terms of
computational data
all right yeah that's fantastic and um
students and other people who are
interested in this how can they access
this functionality
uh it's accessible now it should be
available to everybody who has an office
365 subscription so it's not it's not
something that's just available to
people who get
whatever core office or excel is um but
and and there are different
subscription levels for students and
companies and other things but
anybody who's got office 365
the data types functionality is out
you've got access to again
100 plus different entity types
there are more that we're constantly
working on trying to expose in excel and
figure out
you know what domains are going to be
interesting what properties are going to
be most useful in excel
improving functionality for the things
that we've already got available
it's it's a really exciting partnership
and and really great to i think have
have microsoft have recognized us as as
the people to go to for uh computational
data in something like this yeah it
seems like a really kind of
i hate to say synergistic but it really
does seem like a nice synergistic
integration
well they the end when they when they
came to us you know the things like the
the stocks currency and geography things
that was functionality they had already
built
and it was really interesting when we
first started talking them to to realize
and we don't always find this kind of
that we were very much in sync with
thinking about
you know down to the terminology just
thinking about entities and properties
and and exposing those in in excel and
it just was a very very natural fit for
the way we had designed things to work
in entity value in the wolfram language
um you know technical hurdles a lot of
things to figure out and making things
work through their apis and bringing
things into excel and making things work
cleanly
but uh
you know just the the the general
way of thinking about knowledge and and
organizing knowledge
uh was
completely in sync with how we've been
approaching it for for years so that was
that made that was very easy at least on
that front
yeah i imagine that definitely helps
kind of get everybody
synced up up to speed really quickly
yeah
yeah i mean there's there's other things
that we're we're working on you know
trying to
there's a there's a general search
integration there's other kinds of
trying to make it possible for people
not just to
uh you know copy paste data into the
excel sheet but actually
you know run natural language queries in
the sidebar and and get some data back
you know trying trying to figure out
ways that are a little more natural for
people to
um
discover data in excel and not just
bring data in and and try to work with
it
yeah that sounds like a nice next step
for this partnership yeah
yeah but they've been a good partner and
it's a really exciting thing to see
going out to users
well thanks a lot alan for telling us
about this interesting partnership with
microsoft and giving us some examples of
what can be done with the wolfram alpha
integration in excel
yeah absolutely it's uh it's been a lot
of fun to work on
that was alan who told us about our
partnership with microsoft and the
integration that we have with our
wolfram knowledge types in excel i'm
looking forward to seeing what they come
up with next and stay tuned for more
tech talks
[Music]
you